that were days after being sanctioned by
the uk government roman abramovich has
now been disqualified as the director of
the football club he owns chelsea the
sanctioning of the club owner on
thursday saw the russian-israeli
billionaire's uk assets frozen now that
measure prevents chelsea from being sold
and it stops the club from selling
tickets or merchandise uh mr
abramovich's super yacht docked in
montenegro's territorial waters this
morning the 140 meter solaris which
sails under a bermuda flag according to
the monitoring site marine traffic was
seen off the coast of the resort town of
tivat
our city editor mark lyman joins us on
the phone to bring us the latest on the
future of chelsea football club
yes some fresh developments this
afternoon concerning the future of
chelsea following the government's
decision to sanction roman abramovich
we're getting a little more clarity
about some of the parties who want to
buy last season's champions league
winners but what i can reveal today is
that sir martin broughton a prominent
figure from the world of business
and a lifelong chelsea fan is in talks
about spearheading one of the consortia
that's aiming to table an offer ahead of
a deadline for bids next friday now sir
martin he used to be the chairman of
british airways is talking to bidders
including todd bowley the part owner of
the los angeles dodgers major league
baseball team and his bid for chelsea is
also i understand backed by jonathan
goldstein a prominent london property
developer now to martin's involvement in
the sale of chelsea is intriguing
because 12 years ago
he was brought in to orchestrate the
sale of liverpool fc when it was gripped
by a bitter boardroom fight and he
remains the only person to have affected
effected the change of ownership at a
major football club at the behest of the
british government which he did at
liverpool when its main lender was the
state controlled world bank of scotland
and mr samartin told me today that the
bidders for chelsea must
work with the government to prevent the
club going into administration because
if it did collapse into insolvency that
would uh reduce the club's valuation by
at least 500 million pounds in his view
now all this comes on another frenetic
day at centre bridge with the premier
league having disqualified mr abramovic
as a director and the government
amending chelsea's licence to operate in
a way which gives it a bit more
financial flexibility by enabling it to
receive and spend broadcast income and
prize money the picture should
surrounding the future of chelsea become
a little clearer after that big deadline
passes next week but for now the future
of one of england's most prestigious and
successful football clubs remains
shrouded in uncertainty